عمد عماد على توظيف تخصصه لخدمه الحجاج
مشاهد حشود الحجاج التي كان يراها في
طفولته بمكه دفعته الى البدء بدراسه بحثيه
لاداره الحشود عبر الذكاء الاصطناعي
باستخدام الكاميرات المنتشره في المشاعر
يعتمد على تقنيات التحليل الصور بالذكاء
الصناعي الكاميرات موجوده في كل مكان
تقريبا فيها اكثر من الف كاميرا موجوده في
المشاعر المقدسه
نقوم عند الحصول عليها نظام تحليلها وعد
الحشود تبانه كثافه الكثافه العدديه
للحشود
واصدار احصائيات عليها تظهر صور البحثيه
كيفيه قيام النظام بوضع الوان على المناطق
التي تشهد ازدحاما بين الحجاج من ثم ترسل
للاشارات اليا الى المسؤولين للتحرك اهم
نقطه كنا مركزين عليها اللي هو عدد الحشود
وحساب التدفقات في الساعه فرحنا فكره
جديده انه نستخدم المحاكيات محاكيات اداره
الحشود لتدريب الاله على عد الحشود
وبزياده الدقه وبالتالي تطبيقها مره اخرى
على الواقع الحقيقي صعوبات عده تواجه
تطبيق البحث تخفيض اعداد الحجاج خلال
جائحه كورونا احداها لكن عماد يعمل بان
يطبق نظامه للمره الاولى خلال موسم الحج
القادم طبعا اهم نقطه في الافاعي من هذا
الموضوع كله هو تحسين قدره متخذي القرار
تحسين قدره العاملين على اداره الحشود في
اتخاذ القرار التقنيات هذه توفر لهم
معلومات لم يسبق لهم الحصول عليها كانت
معظم العمليات هذه تدار عن طريق البصر
ستساهم تطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي في
مواجهه ابرز تحديات الحج اداره الحشود
لاسيما مع خطتي رفع اعداد الحجاج في
المواسم المقبله عبد المحسن الحربي
العربيه مكه المكرمه